let's make a cup of the world's
strongest coffee I'm topping it with a
super smooth egg cream and we're making
Vietnamese egg coffee uh to come back
the dark bitterness I'm pairing it with
a silky fluffy whipped egg which is made
by whipping together pasteurized egg
yolks and condensed milk this drink is
commonly sold in coffee shops all over
Vietnam and it's one of my favorite ways
to enjoy it the recent Vietnamese coffee
is ranged one of the strongest in the
world is because its beans contain twice
the amount of caffeine compared to a
regular Bean that being said it offers a
super clean boost of energy and is
absolutely delicious